on this episode I talk scheduled tweets
family businesses and how to make people
go above their best
welcome back vaynernation you ask
questions and I answer them this is the
askgaryvee show
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 59 of the askgaryvee
show it's good to be back it is good to
be back everyone Happy New Year Happy
New Year
vaynernation oh can you give me a
vaynernation wristbands can you go find
one not there right next Alex really
excited to be back I feel I feel fresh I
spend a ton of time with the family I
worked a lot more than I wanted to
mainly because I caught the Wine Library
bug I think it's pretty much impossible
if you follow me at all to not realize
that's what happened over the last three
weeks so that's exciting a little bit
back to the future back to my roots
flirting in that world which reminds me
I want all of your 2015 wine buying
vaynernation
wristbands by the way I want all of your
2015 wine buying so I would like you to
stop buying wine from anybody else
besides me vaynernation please email me
how we can do that Gary at Wine Library
back up over Boehner media I don't know
what we'll link here well anything link
nothing will link my can you flash the
living crap out of my email here d-roc
thank you I hope everybody had a
wonderful holiday it was a it was great
to spend time with the kids and family
and and I'm glad football's over
I'm really glad footballs over I know
some people like weight in the comments
will be like footballs not over it's
over for me not watching any of this
crap I by the way weird fun fact I
actually want the Patriots to win the
Super Bowl this year because I want to
hit direct rock-bottom over the last 10
years I've always kind of been into
layoffs so the Jets aren't there because
I want to root against the Patriots this
year I flip the switch I am actually
officially rooting for the New England
Patriots to win the Super Bowl because I
want them to stick it directly in my
mouth let's get to the show Kristen
asked hey Gary can you sum up 2014 in
five words Chris them great question I
can the ask Gary Vee she'll Chris ask
Gary would you support being our
employees writing their own books and
curating their own car
tense dreams and personal brands Chris
is a great question as a matter of fact
first of all India first let's talk
about Chris bribing you and like
attacking you let's let's go over here
to India and you tell the vaynernation
though the vaynernation the story of
actually while you're doing that while
you tell everybody Chris's attack and
bribing I actually gonna bring a prop
for this
that's fine I'll be right back Trouty
alright looking for the microphone for
India's story Chris it was extremely
persistent over the holidays time but
not a lot of people were tweeting
questions and he got his friends to
tweet after his question and tag me and
then he said that he might start bribing
me so it definitely worked here's your
question on the show it didn't work
because you didn't you didn't execute
the the actual bribe gift right you went
Noble but now Chris I want you to know
and we've known each other a long long
long long long time and it's good to
have you on the show that you will need
to send India gift it will need to be
substantial and we will tell the
vaynernation what you got her in a cup
coming episode and so you know this is
really your chance to either be a good
guy or a terrible guy try to can you do
me a favor can you find me Jason
Donnelly he he was going through his
he's floating around he was going
through orientation yeah cool we will uh
we were looking for Jason Donnelly and
we will answer Chris's question with
Jason Donnelly as a human prop to your
question let's go to the next question
I'll interrupt that question when Jason
Donnelly shows up that's how we're doing
it Iraq don't fight me dirac let's move
on
alright here we are to finish off this
answer this is actually tremendous
timing because the question came at the
same exact time that Jason rejoined
vaynermedia Jason you made the vital
devastating mistake to leave vaynermedia
and go somewhere else but then you've
rejoined Boehner today why don't you
tell the vaynernation first just because
I want to hear it and feel good about
myself about why you did that but just
one sentence because I want to actually
answer the question this is hope that's
it all right
you I figured you could answer this
question better than I did so why don't
you tell the vaynernation how I did
support somebody who was writing their
own bucket not only did he support me by
just loving the book he bought copies
and gave it to people throughout the
office and he's been nothing but helpful
and likert best boss ever thanks go work
you gotta make a lost time the bottom
line is of course you know I think that
you can't get away with saying you're
gonna take care of people and and you
want to build around them too many
people want to act like they didn't take
care of everybody but then suppress
people who they think can trump them see
there's something amazing that happens
when you think you're the greatest of
all time you don't think that anybody is
necessarily gonna be able to surpass you
yes you don't need to supress and I mean
that I mean it may sound like a douche
bag thing to say but like I believe so
much in myself that there is no value in
me trying to hold down people that I
think are more talented than me and that
happens every day of the year in
organizations all the time and so for me
show them show them for me if they're
better than me or if they need to fly
the nest well then that's what needs to
happen if that means writing their own
book and building their brand I'm more
than happy to do that and support it I
just believe in fair and in capitalism
and and so not only do I believe in
supporting it I do support it actively
when it happens Clayton wants to know
how do you push your team beyond their
best
clicking great question way to start off
2015 good questions Oh actually I picked
this one right like who doesn't bury
Horowitz's well that was so subconscious
so there's a good question I thought we
should do it I really really really
think that the best way to push somebody
above their own means is to guilt them
into it and I know that's a weird kind
of answer but it is my honest belief
that the thing that drive first of all
everybody's driven by different things
so the real answer to your question is
to use your ear right do you rock zoom
in to my ear right you know the ear is
the key in this scenario because the
truth is the way to push somebody above
their limits is to actually have
individual conversations with them about
what is their holy you know Grail right
like what do they want to accomplish
like Indy and I I like I have a good
feel of some of India's long-term career
ambitions and like that gives me first
of all her knowing that we've even had
that conversation in and itself gives
her a little bit more confidence to work
harder because she's trying to get what
she wants out of it professionally and
knowing that I'm the person that could
most likely make that happen at least in
the context of this world that just even
having the conversation puts her in a
better spot that some people are
literally Rallye driven by straight cash
but truly like like you want to push
somebody like you carrot like hey I know
you love cash I'll give you ten thousand
more if you like you know like and so
you've got to find out what makes people
tick I'm so not motivated by cash that
so many people try to get me to do
things JV with me invest in things do
things speak at things because they and
they think cash is the way of doing
listen I love the cash but is not my
biggest driver and I make a lot of
decisions based on legacy long term
impact on myself by the way not like
long term global impact
you know you know that's not not how I
think I mean I think there's a byproduct
of that but that's not the number one
thing for me but to answer the question
in a general form
I totally do believe the best way to get
that is to guilt and what I mean by
guilt it's a variation of listening
which is not only listening but
delivering in a world where so few
people even begin to listen let alone
delivering on that listening and once
you start doing that people start
realizing let me tell you what's
happening at Vayner it's not super
confusing I know exactly what's going on
in this company it's starting to get old
enough that there's enough things
happening for enough people that it's
really easy to point to Phil Toronto or
just somebody else and be like wait a
minute
we're Steve Unwin like you can start
pointing to oh crap
that person wanted that that person's
getting that that person's happiest crap
I want that and so it's listening and
then delivering which then creates a
scenario where people want to over
deliver because the only way somebody
will over deliver for you because you
asked a very selfish question how can I
get my team to over deliver for me for
my thing it's very simple the best way
to get them to over deliver Jon know
Jack is not a substitute I know where
you're thinking but like no that's not a
substitute and you know the only way to
get somebody to over deliver is to
attack their own selfishness
there's your selfish because you want
more out of your team to help you well
the best way to get that to happen is to
over-deliver against their selfishness I
do believe that guilt is a huge driver
because there's something that I believe
in human beings I mean some people don't
have self-awareness or empathy or these
emotional feelings but so many people
like it's amazing to me now living 20
years professionally like how many
people are not confused eventually they
may be emotional at the time you fire
them or not reward them but boy every
time I run into somebody four seven nine
years down the line I've had a very good
track record of them saying hey I know
why you did that or I mean like crazy
stuff like I had a drug problem
like there's like you know stuff life
right so I would answer your question
like I have before on this show and if
you haven't heard me say it I'll say it
again the single best way to win is to
give 51
percent of the relationship if there was
a jury of 500 people that they would all
agree that you've given 51% to the
relationship and you have to be good
enough to know what to do with the other
49 so I would attack their own
selfishness I would make it so good for
them that you've guilted them in
delivering and be very prepared in your
stomach by making it awesome and them
under-delivering
still being entitled to think they did
deliver and then you being disappointed
you listen to the garyvee show and he
told you and he's so great
at least you think so thank you very
much and you did it and in all four of
these people who you gave $10,000 raises
to yesterday a month later are doing the
same crap they did and it didn't
motivate them at all or you gave them
four weeks off instead of one week off
and they're still just as crappy or you
like got them a babysitter and you pay
for it and they still aren't gratitude
and all these wonderful human
characteristics are not guaranteed but
the best way for you to have it happen
is to consistently keep trying to do it
for that person and then look I just had
a meeting with all these characters
right and but the rest of the team and I
was like look like you may not win on
this team like 2015 I want to take it up
another notch and the consolation prize
is you get to work for one of the best
companies in the world but like you just
might not be able to be on this team
like you've got to be up front you've
got to be fair you got to know when
you're setting up people for victory and
when not you got to do that and then you
get the judge not beforehand way too
many of you are making a mistake
yourself you didn't train you didn't put
the person in position to succeed you're
not communicating properly on what you
expect you're not shooting it straight
you're scared to hurt feelings you're
too much of a dick it could be a million
different reasons why it's not happening
but it is always going to be the
greatest form of meritocracy that you
can create and that starts with your ear
and a tenet and it finishes in my
opinion on a second step move of you
actually delivering on that call
people's Bluffs I live life on calling
people's Bluffs
oh you'll really crush it if you have
another person here now you have to be
good enough back that 49% to afford to
give somebody that person right you may
not have that situation but you might
have to make a decision one of the
quickest ways I grew Wine Library was by
making
thirty thousand dollars a year for five
years in a row because I took all those
monies and I called people's Bluffs and
when they let me down do you think it
hurt my feelings that I wasn't making
forty five instead of thirty it sure did
but then I have my eye on the big prize
sure did now I get to pay double that
salary to speak for one hour because I
felt long-term because I was 23 years
old right you got to know where you're
at if you're 83 and you're watching the
show first of all Big Ups old dog then
second of all second of all you know
maybe you don't need to play the long
game and invest as much maybe it's time
to cash out I'm these weird feelings
that in my 80s I'm gonna be rogas crap
and just like take because I just gave
for so long I don't know you've heard me
say that that's my concern but I can
tell you this
most of the reasons let me phrase if
they work for you all of the reasons
that they're not over delivering against
their best all of those reasons are your
fault Harold asks will you force your
children to partake in the business like
your dad will you be disappointed if
they don't want to my dad never forced
me you know you hear the story on my dad
boy I've said it my dad forced me into
the business he forced me into the
business as like a 14 year old child
child labor dad but but there was you
know my age I never worked at Wine
Library I think one summer of you if
you're listening or watching AJ I know
you worked there one summer but you know
he never worked in the business I think
that you know for my parents look I was
a crap student and and I was a great
like salesman as a kid like it was such
a natural segue to the impact that that
my mom fully believed in and she was
closest to the situation
I have no I'm weird with this issue man
I am I first of all I'm a dark dude can
we go black and white on this who don't
black away darker on the black really
cool I'm a dark dude I we you know they
tell you not to compete with your
children like that's a that's like a top
five flaw in society that will not be
something I'm successful in kids maecius
and I'm sorry I'm her dude like Xander
is two and a half years old he has a
basketball like
set up in the living room and I've
blocked every one of his shots so far
like like to the point where he picks up
a ball if I'm in the room he starts
crying goes now block not like this is
what Xander does even if I'm like 10
minutes away because he knows what's
coming which is he's not scoring until
he can score and so you know I am fine I
love my kids unconditional if they're
slim eels and can't sell water in a
desert well then that's just the way it
ended up being right like Lizzy and I
had sex at the wrong moment if that's
something I cared about like that's what
it is
so I just want them to focus on their
strengths I want to put them in a
position to succeed
I think financially and connections wise
there's a very good chance that that's
going to happen and you know you do the
best you can as you know very much the
way I mean a parent has a lot to do with
the way that I that I run companies that
I think that the people have worked for
me and close to me probably feel really
happy and feel good about my kids
opportunities because I care and I have
no disappointment if they don't want to
work for at that point the New York Jets
you know and so that's it I mean no I
have I've no no hesitation I mean if my
kids go completely the other way and and
are not commerce driven and our
anti-business and our you know want to
live in who knows we're feeding who
knows what doing whatever if they want
to save the one-legged butterfly in some
God knows place in the corner of the
world I'm gonna hope that they're the
best that's saving the one-legged
butterfly I'm gonna try to help them
save the one-legged butterfly and sweep
register one legged butterfly calm we
should I I just will support them
unconditionally as long as they're good
human beings and three people respect
and treat people with the fifty one
forty nine percent thing and be the
bigger man and woman I don't care what
they do as long as they do it in a way
that five thousand arbitrators would say
that's a good person hey Richard will
are here with you too can be a guru you
asked for more questions here's one
you're going on vacation so you'll be
gone for let's say just
for this scenario more than three days
and the question is do you schedule your
tweets and respond when you get back
from vacation do you schedule your
tweets and then respond as you're on
vacation or did you just not tweet at
all remember you two commedia go thanks
Gary you're welcome
I think it's number four you tweet and
you respond because that's what I did
I'm just a communication for two weeks
first of all you never schedule I'm
gonna say it again never in your life
schedule a tweet here's why you're on
vacation for three days you schedule a
tweet or like hey what's your favorite
book and at that exact moment we have
the next national tragedy happen at that
second I had multiple friends scheduled
tweets during the Boston Massacre so
here's the Boston Massacre it's a
terrorist event on US soil the whole
world shuts down right and and my
friends are tweeting like you should buy
my new book it was it was disgusting at
best and it was just it's devastating it
just it's and then and that's the
extreme what about like a lightweight
version like you schedule a tweet and
right at that moment on Twitter
the Cowboys score an important touchdown
and the Governor of New Jersey is
bouncing around and hugging Jerry Jones
and that's all that anybody wants to
talk about and you're a Cowboys fan or
from New Jersey and you're tweeting
about like what's your favorite book and
it makes you seem out of touch there's
no value in scheduling a tweet I've
never done it I don't believe in it I
will never believe in it period now
you're more than welcome like I have on
half my vacations to check out
completely and I highly recommend that I
was so excited about doing that I told
you that's what I would do but
unfortunately or fortunately I caught
the wine library bug and I enjoyed
myself talking about wine constantly on
my vacation when Xander and we should
were in the kids club and doing their
thing there or you know
Lizzy was getting ready for the dinner
or finding my pockets going my way so I
think that um it's a personal thing but
boy do I hate do I hate scheduling a
tweet like don't do it please don't do
it
question of the day two parts answer
them both number one
can I have your wine business yes/no
number two what are you looking forward
to in 2015 you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them
oh crap wait subscribe do I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe